the latest poll we have had from CBS
shows Trump is at 61 percent in the
primary field he's 38 points up on his
next closest rival Ron DeSantis DeSantis
is at 23 percent
so it's a little over a third of the
support that Trump has got
next up Tim Scott and Mike Pence we'll
get to pence in a second after that
Nikki Haley after that Vivek and then
ASA Hutchinson David burgum bergamentum
bergam momentum Larry Elder and Chris
Christie we're still waiting on the
chrysosons the croissants it's it's
going to happen the people are with
Trump very clearly any way you measure
it the question is do the people still
matter to the government